drew is on the line drew is in Wisconsin
I drew how are you great they are so
cool to talk to you how are you doing
better than I deserve sir how are you
very good thank you so much so I had
sort of a moral or ethical maybe a pride
question for you my wife and I are
expecting our first child if everything
goes correctly in four days if the due
dates right congratulations sir thank
you thank you so much and since since we
found out we're pregnant we had a few
family members say oh you got to sign up
for WIC which is the women infants and
children program he'll and my wife and I
were just kind of thinking about that
talking about it and we're just not sure
if is that like a welfare program should
we just tighten our budget down tighter
to do this stuff ourselves or if we
should take that help and I just wanted
to get your opinion on that program well
it is a welfare program it's based on
income in every state and when you you
know if you make too much money you
won't qualify to get the help it's it's
based on lower-income people or people
with no income obviously is what it's
saying yeah we make a little over it we
take home about 32,000 years I think
we're in that range yeah you probably
qualify I don't know what Wisconsin's
guidelines are you probably qualify for
it you know I guess you can investigate
it look at it but yeah it is a welfare
program does that mean that there's that
you're to be shamed for taking it no I
mean it's available to people that make
your income there's nothing evil about
it I think the thing you want to get you
want to be careful of and anyone that's
engaging in a welfare program what's to
be careful of is that it's a temporary
measure because you are going to raise
your income to the point that you
wouldn't qualify I hope right that's the
plan we're and we're working on that and
we're definitely gonna get there yeah
you know I'm you know where I'm getting
at though kind of like we we feel like
we could buckle it down well if you
think
make out without the help then make it
without the help there's nothing there
no shame in that either but it's not to
say that somehow you have morally done
something wrong let's pretend it was
done another way okay let's pretend that
you were attending a church and a couple
my age and their 50s looked over and
said hey there's a young couple that
doesn't make a lot of money and they're
having a baby
and we're going to give them a little
money to help them help them while they
have this baby and I reached over and
gave in reached over and gave you a
thousand dollars as a gift would that be
a sin for you to take that no no it's
the same thing this just runs through
the government instead of through the
church you know I mean you're accepting
charity given your situation getting
you're not lying to get it you know
you're not you're not doing anything
wrong you're not breaking any rules and
you're not making it a way of life
that's the writing you know you're not
you're not going to become dependent on
the government you've got a plan right
to be self-sustaining so I'll let you
off the hook on the shame and the guilt
part of it but I wouldn't blame you if
you just said hey we're going to take
care of ourselves we got this there's
nothing wrong with that
and if you looked at that older couple
in the church and said you know that's
very kind but we got it we're fine and
they said well okay we'll keep our
thousand dollars then right and there'd
be no shame in that either there's no
you know that there's not a ethical or
moral thing here the ethical or moral
thing comes in when you lie to get the
money or when you make it a way of life
okay and it is dumbed you down stolen
your dignity and stolen your potential
yeah
yeah and we have plans to get to raise
their income we're working on them right
now yeah to be somebody yeah and to
financially be somebody you already are
some very bad daddy congratulations so
that's how I see it man so you just look
at it that way and then you can decide
based on that you know and again you I
don't think you're being prideful to
sight now we'll buckle it down and take
it ourselves but also don't think you're
being you know some kind of I don't know
a entitled person or something like that
by just taking off
during taking help that was offered to
you on a temporary basis to turn it
around and by the way by you receiving
the help I don't think it means that
someone else will not receive the help
either there's I mean I think wicks
probably in pretty good shape in
Wisconsin you know hey thanks for the
call - appreciate you joining us hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]